how do they miss so badly on things like
job reports
and inflation well they know i mean back
to
you have to assume i mean janet
yellen and you know chairman powell and
all those people they
it's not like they they have some void
of understanding i mean they're
picture original they're just told they
have a directive
and so they are trying to make people
not panic
they know exactly what it's going to do
and they have to seem optimistic and
they have to say these things because
they need
people to um you know
believe this is a good thing and this
administration's going to do a
do a good job for them because that's
who hired them and
the most it's intellectual it's more
intellectual dishonesty which is why
they need taken down
the most insane example of this was the
job report in i think it was may or
april where they thought there was going
to be a million new jobs added to the
economy and there's 225 000 or 250 000
well it's like 75 miss if every yeah
yeah they should i mean in any other
circumstance they would be fired for
their
incompetence like that's a 25 on the
test
right like that is a big fat f minus
like you may not get invited back to
class
yeah well they don't have to they don't
they don't have to
the federal reserve and meteorologists
they don't have to actually be accurate
for them to sustain their positions i
mean
is that the comparable is the federal
reserve uh
central banker is comparable to a
meteorologist i haven't thought that out
but neither of them
have any consequences for being wrong in
how many people get to say that and
still keep their jobs
yeah is it something where the federal
reserve
uh in their predictions of economic
performance um
whether it's jobs whether it's inflation
interest rate
uh kind of impact whatever we should
adhere to the actual like accuracy of
what they're saying
so if you say hey i think it's gonna be
four percent then
it's either four percent or it's not or
should we think of it more directionally
and just four percent is higher than
where we are and so they're
directionally correct but the number
doesn't actually matter they've entirely
discredited themselves i don't know why
anybody would make any decisions based
on
anything they say there's there's uh
press conferences literally they sit
there and people analyze every single
word they say did they say the word
dovish or not what color is his tie
like i've literally seen these reports
that show
if they wear a certain color of their
tie or they say a certain word or
whatever
it's supposed to signal something to the
market which sounds [ __ ] insane
yeah it's crazy i would never measure
anything they say i i watch it for uh
the the i guess um interesting
insights it'll give me as to how how
much they're willing to lie to people
but that's really only just a scale
just because i'm curious what does that
tell you if they're willing to lie more
than usual does that tell you that
things are
worse better like
they're they're just like the news media
they're just willing to support the
cause because they know they
you know they know who feeds them do you
want to know the one hill that i'm
willing to die on around all this
yes the financial media is a mouthpiece
for the state
oh absolutely there's no distinction
there's no that's state media for sure
that's why
i turned it off so in august
of 2020 i wrote this thing publicly
and uh those that were red pilled
were like spot on everyone else
said i stooped too low i was going after
people stuff and what i wrote was
there's three types of people who create
content in the finance
industry there are the journalists who
do actual journalism i have a story i go
i interview all of the people in the
story
i'm unbiased i fact check i present it
it's not my opinion
it's the facts of the story you as the
reader can read it and you can determine
what you believe from it
there uh that's one end of the spectrum
that's the only side of the spectrum
that i'm willing to entertain
okay there's a second other extreme
end of the spectrum which uh people
usually don't think of as finance media
but i think you'll agree with this one
as well which is what i call
the uh people with skin in the game or
the players in the market
so uh a hedge fund manager writes a
report
and says i believe x to be true and
therefore we've staked
10 million on this outcome or it is a
person who buys bitcoin and says i think
that bitcoin is going to become more
adopted because abc whatever reason
the way that you kind of put a
distinction on these people is
if they are wrong there's financial
consequences right so journalists have
no financial exposure no skin in the
game but they're doing unbiased
uh content the players in the market
they're just making financial bets
they've complete skin of the game and if
they're right they benefit
if they're wrong they get hurt yeah
those two ends of the spectrum i think
people generally agree with okay we
understand who they are
we get it but there's a group in the
middle and i actually think these people
in the middle
are part of the problem they're the
biggest part of the problem which is
they're the bloggers
masquerading as journalists right so
these are the people who
don't do journalism don't fact check
things they write their opinion
as as if it is fact and then they
publish
under the title of journalist and then
they get cited as a source that's
credible
and and this is how the lies disseminate
and how they
they're just oh this person's on our
side of the war
and it clouds the truth and it's it's
really too bad but um you know ever
since we
reward clicks truth is clouded
the worst part is that these people are
constantly wrong and there are no
repercussions if you're a journalist
doing journalism and you're wrong that
means it's inaccurate and therefore you
are either fired
or you have to retract it and correct it
even retractions get so buried i mean
nobody really agreed but at least
there's a path
to correcting the inaccuracy when you
are a blogger masquerading as a
journalist
first of all the media companies are
lying because they do not put the
opinion pieces in the opinion section
they put them as
journalism the second thing is that when
you are wrong there's no retractions and
there's no punishment for being wrong
although all of the news is
editorializing the opinion
you know and you get approved and put on
cnn based upon
not your ability to relay the truth but
your ability to be on
their side of the culture war that's the
credibility resume that they
so here's the best part of this whole
thing there's two specific
journalists that i'll put in air quotes
those journalists
uh work at a very large media company i
wrote
this article with them and a number of
their colleagues in mind
they just launched under that media
brand a blog
a very well known financial media
organization now has
two of their people one is a editor and
the other
is a financial journalist they said we
are launching our blog we are going back
to blogging
and they are now going to go build out
this whole thing but they still
publish on the main site under the title
of journalist
and the pieces aren't labeled as opinion
and therefore when you look at that you
realize
that that organization has lost all
credibility
because they are allowing
non-journalists
to pretend to be journalists it's just
another way to
make a little extra money and and that's
that's why the news is just something
now i
you give no credibility like how can i
it is literally the corporate media
yeah and not only are they wrong
they financially get people hurt all the
time
and they're complete sellouts right i
mean like that's all it is i mean
it's frankly it's disgusting right i
still listen to you because you're
willing to say that so when you see a
sellout you should say that
i do and then everyone gets really mad
it's okay trust me i've been saying it
for a long time i don't care
i think that the part that becomes uh a
little bit further down this path
is when you then say these same people
if you go look at what they're writing
they literally parrot the talking points
of the state they are a propaganda
machine
it's a it's a network that's
self-rewarding
do you know why they're a propaganda
machine why because the owner of the
organization is a billionaire
and that billionaire has financial
interest yes and that media arm
is there to protect his financial
interests yes and
and we don't call that out because they
hide and say we're doing journalism we
have a
you know a firewall between the
financial interest and our
our media publication but when you
actually look at it
that's not true and not only are they
protecting his financial interests
they're also continuing to parrot the
talking points of the state
which desensitizes people to what the
state is doing to what the central bank
is doing
and when you get into this whole
spiraling out of control
you realize now we're sitting here and
over the last 12 months 14 months
everyone who is red pilled who's in the
bitcoin community has been yelling and
screaming that inflation was coming
these same idiots were writing last year
saying inflation wasn't coming
yeah now they're saying it's transit
influencers right
yeah now now it's not going to be here
forever
even to the point of some of them saying
that when prices of consumer goods are
going up
or commodities are going up has nothing
to do with inflation
yeah because once you take the
intellectually honest approach of
knowing cause and effect
and going on camera and saying it then
people are like well maybe we shouldn't
print money maybe it's not the greatest
thing to do
so then they get pushback and they don't
want that they want to just squash any
narrative
of any kind of decisive alternative
opinion because then they don't have to
deal with it